[Music]
Kobe Bryant was one of the best players
to ever lace up a basketball shoe what
those people went through and how did
they manage to come out of it and we
shall coherent and clear and positive I
mean it's amazing tribute to the human
spirit
I wanted to be going places where she
people went before operating complex
machines and helped gather data that
helps make life better and took her
that's why we go into space to make life
better on earth I mean there's a part of
me which kind of likes the sort of I
like the world was stunned earlier this
week to learn of the tragic death of LA
Lakers star Kobe Bryant the basketball
legend was killed in a helicopter crash
along with his daughter Gianna and seven
others nicknamed Black Mamba he was one
of the greatest NBA players on all time
I spoke to british-born
former Laker Steve Bucknam about what
made Kobe Bryant such a giant at the
game Kobe Bryant was one of the best
players to ever lace up a basketball
shoe I mean they're his legacies is all
written down and documented and he meant
so much to the sport so much to the
Laker nation and so much to the sporting
nation and all a great tragedy your work
with basketball England now how does
Kobe Bryant inspire the next generation
of players what's his legacy what's his
impact I think what I'll highlight about
Kobe is as we've talked about before his
his work ethic is is truly incredible
work ethic and meticulous eye for
details I think all our young players
need to pay attention he did he didn't
just get to the top by waking up one
morning and picking up a basketball he
really worked hard at it and I think it
proves that if you have some talent and
you and you dedicate yourself to to hard
work and listening to your coaches and
having good people around you you can be
successful and I think
or kids need to to look at his life look
at what what he's done for basketball
not just during his playing days but
even now he set up his Academy he's
working with the young people he's he's
somebody that that really wants to leave
a mark and has left a mark in basketball
forever and he was a one team man as
well he went straight from high school
into the NBA and he is with the LA
Lakers throughout and he had so much
success with that one team I think their
loyalty we don't talk about that now in
sports but you know he was he was loyal
to the Lakers yeah I believe he went
there 18 19 years old and he never left
and he stuck with that program through
his ups and downs mostly ups of course
with the five championships but he was a
stalwart and they and they built a
foundation on that that's taken him
through now LeBron James is trying to
carry that on talk to me about the
impact on that city he really was a
giant in LA yeah playing basketball for
the Lakers is a tremendous honor and the
whole city gets behind you and you know
the Laker nation gets behind you and and
Kobe's has been seen for over two
decades as the the number one sportsman
out there so his impact is devastating
to see what's happened now with his past
in a way people are still trying to
comprehend it I think people can't
believe it I'm still in shocked and you
know we need to mourn we need time to
mourn and understand this this guy was
one of the greatest
[Music]
nor now on the 75th anniversary of the
liberation of Auschwitz which was marked
today with the ceremony featuring some
of the survivors of the death camps
joining me now is Lord dubs her Labour
peer of course it was a child escaped
the Nazis and came to the United Kingdom
very good to see Lord Anse
do you often think as you watched scenes
such as we've seen today at Auschwitz
what would what might have happened to
your family your immediate family if you
hadn't been able to get out of
Czechoslovakia yeah I suppose I suppose
I do my uncle aunt ended up in Auschwitz
so I do my parents were lucky there but
different means they escaped that but I
certainly do think about it and pretty
well most of our family either fled the
fled Czechoslovakia or ended up in the
camps and friends in family and so let's
just fill people in who don't know your
your story I mean you really you and you
as say your immediate family got out in
the nick of time
my father fled the day the Germans
occupied Prague in March 1939 and then
my mother was a fuse permission to leave
and she put got me on a kinder transport
so I arrived in London in July 1939
which was after all two months before
the war began what do you make the
testimony we've been hearing today from
some of the the last survivors well
pretty soon there aren't going to be
anyone isn't going to be anyone left who
were actually in the gun no I found some
of the testimonies I've heard today and
earlier very painful and and I think
what what those people went through and
how did they manage to come out of it
and be so coherent and clear and
positive I mean it's an amazing tribute
to the human spirit but of course so
many of them so many of their friends
and relatives didn't survive so there's
a terrible tragedy overhanging zone so
how do we keep that that memory going in
there lessons that emanate from it
publicity such as you're doing thank you
thanks thanks to this the Holocaust
Memorial Day Trust has had events I've
been to two or three of them today big
one at central hall Westminster
the whole family will the Prince William
Ozzy and so on and I think we have to do
it in schools as well I think we have to
make sure that young people understand
what's happening and some of the
organizations that perpetuate the
message or spread the message they have
young people who are ambassadors who go
to school go on schools and telling them
I think we've got to educate the young
people I was in a school in Bethnal
Green about two years ago maintain
school but it's all Muslim boys and
their project was the Holocaust and
Kindertransport and one of the muslim
boy said to me what do i say to somebody
who denies the Holocaust ever happened I
think that's a terrific tribute to that
school terrific that Muslim boys are
asking those sort of sensible
far-reaching questions
[Music]
would let's say that the Antarctic
Explorer Jenny Davis joins us now in the
studio and been there a couple of times
now yes
second trip where did you when did you
get back and about a week ago
yeah which have been a short stint in
hospitals since getting back but I mean
I I'm very excited to be let out so you
were trying to get to the pole you tried
last year couple years ago and had
health problems that stopped you tried
again didn't you didn't break the record
you were hoping to break yes so the
record I was going for is he saw the
speed record to go from the coastline of
Antarctica to the South Pole
it's just 700 miles and the woman's
record which still stands and I really
hope there's someone at home watching
he'd like to come and break it and I'll
be there helping them every step of the
way and but I did it in 42 days I'm so
just shy I was on pace for the world
record for 420 miles just over and
unfortunately when I got this injury on
my leg it's called polar thighs from
with kind of cold injury I slowed right
down so the skiing went from 16 hours a
day to about 14 and I was in a great
deal of pain and but their goal was to
reach the pole and I did that so I'm
I've genuinely overjoyed that I did why
go why do it I think if you have to ask
I I don't know there's so many answers
long answers to that question and it's
something I wanted to do since I was a
teenager and I followed Antarctic
history since then and I've seen other
woman do it and I've looked up to them
in a big way and it's just something
I've always wanted to go and do it's a
long time to be by yourself and I get
that 42 days and this old she's never
been the issue for me and I really
wanted to see what I could do out there
it's been 200 years since since it was
discovered in the vertical for a little
longer than that so much research has
been carried out I mean is there
anything left to learn from Antarctica
so much of Antarctica has not been
explored and maybe there's an argument
to be made that it should stay that way
and but yeah it's such an enormous
country and people realize just how big
it really is and B I think it still has
a lot left to offer and
of expiration will you go again I mean
you've given it a go twice yeah so the
first time I had a bowel infection that
was medevacked with peritonitis and that
was far more serious and what's happened
in my leg this time and no I don't know
go back already something that draws you
back to Antarctica and I just kind of
explained it with the first time I was
there I've made it quite clear this is
the one only time I'd be going to
Antarctica it's expensive to go to as a
tourist which I guess ultimately I am
even as a polar explorer and and I find
myself back there again
and so yeah maybe in some shade before
whether it's as a guide or doing trips
they will see that I can't imagine it's
my last time nine years actually since
NASA launched the last man's shuttle
flight but now the agency has big plans
for the future with us is Steve Smith
he's a former shuttle mission specialist
and one of NASA's most experienced
astronauts this Atlantis is one of our
space shuttles that we've retired now as
you said this one is located at the
Kennedy Visitor Complex in Florida so
our guests can see that that's the
shuttle i phone on my last flight to fix
to build the Hubble on the International
Space Station do you miss being in space
I do I dream about it two or three times
per year
yeah spacewalk or steal a jet and go
flying I always wake up and tell my wife
I was in space again but even you
haven't been to the moon no no no one's
been to the moon since the early 1970s
but we're going back as you may know so
there's this effort to be back on the
moon within the next four or five years
and I think we'll see the first woman
step on the moon at that time say we
hope so what happened in that decade
when when the shuttles were retired sure
so it would have been nice to have had
the follow-on spacecraft available right
away when the shuttle was done but
because of all the challenges we have in
our funding we are still working on the
new one so in the meantime we've been
riding on Russian rockets to get our
astronauts and European astronauts like
Timothy Peake and so now the new
vehicles just about ready so that's what
flam within the next year actually just
to go and low-earth orbit and the back
to the minute after that why do we want
to go back to the main well there's a
lot of things that we weren't able to do
back in the 1970s because we didn't have
the technology in terms of research but
the real main point is that the moon is
fairly close to Earth so it's about a
three-day trip and if we want to go on
to Mars the moon is a great place to
practice things and to try new
technology but getting to Mars is yes
that's very difficult yeah it's very
difficult I think the technology will be
ready in the next few years but it takes
about nine months to get there and go
back and to put a human in space for
that long would be over two years
because you want to stay at Mars for a
while the human body just can't take it
so that's the big challenge why do you
want to be an astronaut
oh I grew up under the influence of the
Explorers of the day Jacques Cousteau
and all the astronauts and cosmonauts
and for me I wanted to be going places
where few people went before operating
complex machines and help gather data
that helps make life better and in
particular that's why we go into space
to make life better on earth
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now for 16 years he's been the
soundtrack to the England cricket team
now the Barney armies trumpeter is
retiring the current test against South
Africa will be the last time Billy
Cooper entertains England fans with his
well known hits
well joined from central London by
therefore making him in the cricket sir
Monty Panesar once you really get to
talk it does put a smile on your face
your reaction to the news after Billy
Cooper is a hanging up the trumpets yeah
I think Billy Cooper was you know what's
the kind of the faithful you know barmy
army and I think the you know they're
the best support was you know in the
world and I'm sure you know the songs
that he that they've that he's created
and you know numerous wickets you know
that he's helped us care you know during
tough situations in in a Test match you
know we thank Billy Cooper and you know
he's been absolutely brilliant you know
for barmy army and you know for cricket
fans around the world what can you tell
me about the atmosphere that here
contributes hisui I think when things
were going when there was nothing going
on here we would hear the trumpet and it
will get the get the crowd going get us
going you know provide us with a lot of
energy passion and then suddenly you
know it will lift our spirits and and
once we get a wicket suddenly we're on a
roll and he was brilliant at that you
know he's absolutely brilliant at you
know providing the a lot of sort of
entertainment a lot of support and you
know he's first obviously became famous
in 2005 you know during the during the
ashes when England won and and since
then in a barmy army has just gone you
know strength to strength yeah I'm you
often hear from professional sports
personalities that you can't
underestimate some of the importance of
the crowd and Billy was one of those
people that inspired that crowd to
support you and your teammates yeah
absolutely I thought really was you know
just brilliant you know loyal loyal
supporter and I think that times you
know I remember when I needed a wicket
you know Billy Cooper helped me out a
lot and I'm sure he's helped you know
many numerous you know test bowlers
test captain so you know we just thank
him thank him you know for their effort
and for his passion and his commitment
on supporting you know English cricket
five weeks two days this film is so
unique tell me what went through your
mind when the script came to you what
were your first thoughts I thought it
was very original and I'd been I was
reading a lot of scripts at the time and
it just really really really stood out
and I wanted to work with Robert anyway
I really liked him and I loved the witch
and there was just something so
fascinating about it and it was it's
really ambitious and really it felt very
well researched and very rich just felt
like a world when you read it and nice
and also when you get these characters
tuned it's such extreme behavior like
it's really just nearly really fun to
play you have some really intimate
scenes and I'm intrigued as an actor how
do you break down those barriers and
perform such extreme kind of in-depth
things but normally in everyday life you
just don't do I mean there's a part of
me which kind of likes the sort of I
like perversity in something you kind of
think I don't know I think a lot of
people like to play things pretty safe
and like once you once you kind of
broken that fear of whatever and you
just do it once now I don't know I
realize I don't actually care what
people think it's like and it's fun and
there's something when you can kind of
the crazier something is I don't know
especially when it when it works like
there's some people you know you can
people come out of a movie theater be
like what was that I mean it's kind of
it's an exciting feeling like you're
just sort of that's just the world I
want to I want to be part of
and it's also I never really see
something as this there's something
weirdly protected about doing a new
movie doing almost anything in a movie
even though more people will see it like
it's like there's just that little
strange line and I say it's not real
when it's saying but it is real kids
it's really bizarre I'm a lot more
confident there's a camera there than
that isn't just bizarre all right have
it your way
the last fighter ace of the Battle of
Britain has died meaning just two of the
so-called few are still known to be
alive Wing Commander Paul Farnes died
peacefully in hospital in Sussex on
Tuesday morning aged 101 he was one of
3,000 Airmen who defended the skies
against the Luftwaffe over southern
England in the summer of 1940 I'm joined
from Kent by Patrick total from the
Battle of Britain Memorial Trust he was
a proper ace wasn't he destroying what
six enemy aircraft and I think damage 6
as well is that right that's right and
of course he was and also an ace in the
Battle of France as well he became an
ace after you've shot down five
aeroplanes
you got to know him and his family what
sort of man was he Oh a very gentle man
I mean he he didn't suffer fools gladly
he hated bureaucracy but on the other
hand he was very kind and he really
engaged with everybody I mean a great
pride was his family and also coming to
events and sort of being represented
there he sometimes felt a bit
embarrassed when they all clapped when
we left Weston Thea be
now Patrick since you retired from the
RAF you've dedicated your life to making
sure the Battle of Britain is remembered
presumably it gets more difficult as
these heroes pass on yes that's a
popular conception but we found as a
power saw as new generation gets
involved not the immediate post-war
generation like I was but young people
today and particularly the grandchildren
and all the rest are very involved now
and when we go to schools and they come
round they are incredibly interested so
there's no no waning of the interest in
the Battle of Britain which was so so
important to this country and perhaps
the world we wouldn't be celebrating VE
Day in May if we haven't won the Battle
of Britain absolutely but they do take
their stories with them don't they what
other ways Patrick can you make sure
that these men are not forgotten well
very early on when we set up our wing
our new visitors center in about 2010 we
did a series of interviews with about 12
of them who are still with us and could
run speak well so we've got those in our
archives and we'll keep those to play to
our visitors when they come and see us
[Music]
the school in Hampshire has teamed up
with a Ugandan orphan kids choir to give
them a chance to come to the UK perform
and raise awareness about their life
Brighton Hill School in Beijing State
raised nearly ten thousand pounds during
these children all the way over from
Uganda over the past couple of weeks the
Kings kid choir have sung has some
pretty impressive locations including
Westminster Hall and I'm very pleased to
say that the choir with me now hello to
you big smiles and some big voices as
well he should have heard them in
rehearsal also here headmaster of
Brighton Hill School Chris Edwards and
Robert Mopani who's the lead pastor at
Kings kid ministries international he
came here to the UK with this rather
wonderful choir well welcome to you all
and Chris I first want to ask how this
special relationship between your school
in Hampshire came about with the
orphanage in Uganda yeah well one of our
governors is Reverend of the local
Baptist Church and he knew Robert and he
brought Robert over and I took the
opportunity to get Robert to do an
assembly with our year eights at the
time and we were quite moved by the
story of the choir and at the end of his
assembly I got up and promised that we'd
raise enough money to fly them over
without really thinking about it and
sort of hope they might forget about it
then he emailed me and told me told the
children and that there were tears of
joy so we couldn't really go back so our
children the staff have raised nine
thousand pounds to fly these guys over
here but it's been worth every penny
tell me about the orphanage and some of
the work you do there well thank you the
king's kid there is is a is a whole
ministry but specifically these
children's or children's home we work
with over 300 children that have
otherwise have not parents or their
parents at dysfunctional families and we
take care of them on a full-time basis
feeding them dressing them and giving
them an education
Robert understand the children are going
to sing for us so what song are they
singing or they have a wonderful
acapella called the Hallelujah so they
are seeing that well let's take it away
shall we
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]